As we go to our next game,
Secret Service Code Names.
The Secret Service has given
a code name
to meringue-boned Democratic
candidate Bernie Sanders,
and that name is Intrepid.
Intrepid is also the brand name
of Bernie's Canadian
dry mouth medication.
Uh, the Secret... He's very old.
The Secret... the Secret Service
has been doing this for years,
from Ronald Reagan,
whose code name was Rawhide,
to George W. Bush,
whose code name was Shortbus.
So, comedians, I'm gonna show
you some political figures,
and I want you to give me
their code names.
First up, Vladimir Putin.
Vladimir Putin. Craig Ferguson.
Pussy Riot!
(bleep). Points.
Next up, Angela Merkel.
Angela Merkel. Kurt.
SpongeBarb SquarePants!
-Yes, points!
-All right!
Next up, Kim Jong-un.
Kim Jong-un. Mary Lynn.
Kim Kardash-hole.
Points. Oh, so good.
Next up, Ted Cruz.
-Ferguson.
-Repulso!
Points.
Next up, Hillary Clinton.
-Hillary Clinton. Kurt
Braunohler. -Mrs. President!
-Points.
-(light whooping, groaning)
-Uh, next...
-Wha... -(laughter)
Next up, Martin Shkreli.
-Kurt.
-Beelzebub.
Yes, points.
Finally, the Koch brothers.
-Mary Lynn.
-Hall and Oates.
Yes, points! Very good.